well it's a concern many of us have
someone coming to our door when we're
not expecting them right well that's the
case for a sky canyon resident who is
concerned about salesmen spotted in his
neighborhood especially after recent
break-ins joe moeller is live near sky
canyon park drive and the 95 with what
he has to say joe
a lot of you have reached out to eight
news now and you become victim of a home
break-in and have video on now more
people are getting concerned about
unwanted guests at the front door today
we caught up with the sky canyon man who
was concerned about the knock at his
front door and he doesn't know exactly
where to turn
friday these men knocked on the door in
the sky canyon area the guy who rang the
doorbell immediately tried to open the
front door the red iron door and then he
reached up top and started searching for
a key this man roger did not want to
show his face i noticed they had brink
shirts on i don't think that would be
something that a regular brinks
representative would do he says he has a
security sign out front and doesn't know
if these guys are legitimate he says no
neighbors saw them and they drove off in
a red two-door unmarked car it's real
easy for somebody to pose as a brinks
person nearly two weeks ago this
break-in happened in spring valley first
a man knocked disappeared and then came
back only to bust the door in he says
these and other posts on next door are a
concern we're just trying to get the
awareness out he took it to next door
after he saw comments that brinks does
not go door to door concern grew
according to a post on the brink's home
security website they suspended
door-to-door sales briefly during the
pandemic but then resumed in certain
areas they did have a phone number for
people to call about door-to-door sales
people to me the face doesn't even match
the id rogers said he was worried about
the interaction and knew it was best not
to answer even on brink's website they
said if somebody rings your doorbell and
you didn't invite him here don't open
the door to him
back out here live we did reach out to
brink's home corporate and we were
waiting to get a response from them but
according to their website if a sales
person does come to the door they will
have an id and tell you what company
they are coming from reporting live in
sky canyon this evening john muller live
local now